- This is a rectangle.
And yes, this is a rectangle.
Let's measure the green line below
using both rectangles
and a centimeter ruler.
So, we have this green line
and we're going to measure
it in terms of rectangles
and we're going to
measure it on this ruler.
And you immediately see
the green line is equal
to one rectangle long,
but if we measure it in centimeters
it's equal to six centimeters long.
So we can say the line
is one rectangle long,
but it's six centimeters long
and that makes sense
because the rectangle is much more
than a centimeter.
Actually, the length of a
rectangle is six centimeters.
So, the length of a rectangle is longer
than a centimeter.
You see that.
This is the length of the rectangle,
it's the same as the line,
while centimeter is this length.
The rectangle is actually
six centimeters long.
So it takes blank rectangles,
than centimeters,
to measure the line.
Well, since the rectangle is longer,
it takes fewer rectangles than centimeters
to measure the line.
So it's fewer rectangles than centimeters
and you see that.
Fewer rectangles,
one is fewer than six.
It took one,
it only took one rectangle
to measure the line
because a rectangle's so long
and it took six centimeters
to measure the line.
So it took fewer
rectangles than centimeters
to measure the line.
Let's keep going.
Alright, so we have.
This is a rectangle.
Yes, that is a rectangle.
Let's measure the blue line below
using both a rectangle
and a centimeter ruler.
So it's a similar idea.
So, when we look at this blue line,
the line is now two of
these green rectangles long.
So it is two rectangles long.
Now, in terms of centimeters,
it is four,
four centimeters long.
Four centimeters long.
The length of each rectangle is blank
than a centimeter.
Well, each rectangle is
more than a centimeter.
It's longer.
You see, each rectangle is
actually two centimeters.
So, it's longer than a centimeter.
So it takes blank
rectangles than centimeters
to measure the line.
Well, since each rectangle is longer,
it's going to take fewer rectangles
to measure the line.
So we'll select fewer right over there
and you see that over here.
It only took two rectangles
to measure the line,
but it took four centimeters.
Two is fewer than four.
Let's see.
Let's do one more of these.
These are a lot of fun.
Alright, this is a rectangle.
Let's measure the green line below.
Same idea.
The line is four rectangles long.
The line is seven centimeters long.
The length of each rectangle is shorter,
sorry, longer than a centimeter.
You see that right here.
Each rectangle is more
than one centimeter.
So it takes fewer
rectangles than centimeters
to measure the line.
So, we've seen this,
we've seen this multiple times.